hey Dan hey uh some people thought we
were a little unprofessional yes sir I
would like unprofessional gala back into
professionals That's not me okay let me
get back into professional Dan mode can
you do it oh I can do it I'm there
already I'm always there that's where I
operate that's where I live all right
hi guys this is Kate's my knees and my
name's Jess what's this bit first up
ahead of the best time of year to game
awards and PlayStation experience it
looks like the release date for God of
War might have leaked I've spotted by
everyone's favorite online personality
Wario 64 the US PlayStation Store
briefly listed the game's release date
as March 22nd 2018 it's since been
updated back to December 31st 2018 so
take this one with a grain of salt at
this year's e3 Game Director Corey Balog
spoke about how the game will offer a
more diverse emotional palette than the
previous games so you know not just
shouty angst this time hopefully we get
some details on this one via the
aforementioned game Awards and
PlayStation experience don't fret if you
can't make the cringe-inducing
spectacular that is the gamer with most
years we'll be covering everything there
is to see from the show and the
PlayStation specific show this weekend
not long now until player Noons
battlegrounds makes its way to Xbox one
and ahead of that release Blue Hole have
revealed some new details about the
upcoming map currently pub G only has 1
map but blue Holub said they're
currently working on two more what is a
snow map that is still a while away but
the second a desert theme map is set to
release very soon we know that we'll get
our first look at the map during the
game awards but pub G's official Twitter
account has revealed a screenshot of a
new vehicle
recently Blue Hole tested a bunch of
changes including new ballistics and
vaulting ahead of the games planned for
release date sometime in December
you know the pub gene used the lead game
designer chang-gyum Kim told PC gamer
that the company is considering adding
more cosmetic items to the games loot
boxes but suggested they would never
take the route of pay2win Blue Hole is
also considering adding a tutorial or
shooting range to pub G even though the
developers designed it to be punishing
saying alpha was there's a nerve
practice in life it should be tough
since delivering the reality was
important the 100 player virtual
hide-and-seek game hits consoles by the
Xbox one's game preview program
on December 12th finally there are some
elements of Star Wars Battlefront - that
don't want your dollars and one of them
is the fact that all of the upcoming DLC
will be free the first season kicks off
today with the last Jedi season of
content the first slew of updates will
be themed around the upcoming Star Wars
movie except one is you're now able to
ally yourself with the first order or
New Republic and doing so presents you
with special weekly faction quests with
rewards that correspond to your side
DICE's explained completing these will
not only reward you with credits and
crafting parts but help edge your
faction closer to victory
giving all members of that side an
additional reward the other faction will
get a crate of their own with lesser
prizes but it will hopefully come with a
drive to fight back even harder your
first challenge is to rack up 50 kills
with each trooper class but you have
until the end of the season to do it and
can complete challenges in any order on
December 13th battlefront 2 is adding
Captain phasma and Finn to the character
roster as well as two new maps set on
crate and a car a new vehicle and new
challenges the single-player side won't
be left out either as a new mission
called resurrection will arrive at the
same time as everything we have for you
today enjoy the rest of your day and
we'll see you guys tomorrow Thursday and
Friday and yeah we wrap right at this
year's e3 Game Director kori bolt is it
Barlow Kyla I always thought it was
Balrog her hug isn't that yeah I mean
I'm gonna have a really hard time saying
ba load at this is